imagine how much you care about your
mother's opinion and your father's
opinion and all of those other people
can now imagine that there's literally
only one because I had no siblings I
basically had no mother I had just a
father and so like his approval was
literally everything and he disapproved
of the path that I wanted to take in my
life I think a lot of these mental
faculties are these little Frameworks
just came from like how can I combat
this incredibly booming voice in the
background because like when I look at
what I was doing at the time I graduated
in three years I took the consulting job
I did all the things but the craziest
thing was that the moment that my father
was most proud of me and he approved of
my life the most was when I was the
saddest
maybe his approval isn't the right way
to feel good about life